and Drake had a kid with a stripper but
high quality women will definitely not
sleep a drink and so many other
restaurants
you don't have to you don't have to high
quality women like let's say what is but
that's the thing like what is a high
quality one I will tell you like I'm
sorry I'm just like people from the
parliament people in the in the in the
politicians they won't do that they
don't want their names
but here's the thing the other man they
keep it low-key you there's a respect
put respect on the name you realize like
and put the respect on my name as well
NBA players have women that like
actively pursue them to the point
they'll like buy hotel rooms like at the
places look to look for where they hang
out and also like know everything about
like they literally personally this is
what they do I'll tell you what they do
right
watch out this info because I okay cool
I know I know this info because I have
personal assist a lot of influences and
some celebs in the UK so I've seen some
behind the scenes of what goes on and
how it works is that
I don't know like an artist or an NBA
player or something I've never worked at
MP player but I'm just saying someone of
that status will go through someone else
and say I'm requesting a girl that's
this age this and this they will Scout
for the girl oh yeah they would say cool
this person
um wants you for the night they require
X Y and Z and that's how it works it's
not even always it wouldn't be just
Drake himself they all do it they all do
it all the contracts there's so many
contracts and that contracts will have
it in D.A to not mention their names
that's what I'm saying yeah but this is
what I'm saying about it sharing about
it openly does damage your partner name
and their you know quality of who they
are not not necessarily it depends on
your Lane right but if you're going to
so many serious I would say
um position it will impact you you know
I'm not saying man don't cheat to woman
cheat most of the time you don't know
about it and just life keeps going on
and you I said you're okay with that
right like not not to like use him as an
example but like if he were to cheat and
you didn't know about it would you be
okay with it would I listen logically
right I come from a culture when Dude
okay right I I would I'll be angry if I
knew
I will accept it I have to say there is
so much qualities about my partner if he
done one mistake in so many years I'll
just keep a blind eye I get one pass can
I ask you a question
do you feel like do you feel like you
respect your I don't know how long ago
your previous girlfriends were when he
was living together but did do you think
you respect them the same as you do your
now girlfriend yeah why no equally I
heard a lot more okay
she's like everything I'm looking for
like in terms of you know like she's
very intelligent she's hyper analytical
like me
just fantasy sorry babe these other
girls just fantasies like fight you off
like like your playground
oh the the side girls yeah yeah because
I I enjoy going through almost like
someone that got good at chess and it
sounds like the whole question for you
when you was looking for a wife
did you want to be with someone that was
bisexual to allow those things yes
that's a requirement yeah that was like
your requirement right there's like a
whole list of it has to come from a good
family that's why it works so if you're
happy and I was upfront with it and she
could have left yeah I like the fact
that you're up front with it yeah I
think everyone's relationship is going
to work for them I just wonder how it
would work sorry I'm curious girls who
who would sign up for something like
that yeah anyone I personally wouldn't
in that exact dynamic but I would like
to say I respect you so much because you
had to in a way lower your ego to be
able to have him happy if he's happy
then that's what makes you happy and I
feel like in our society now that's
women's problem including myself the
fact that we don't want to lower our ego
in order to make our partner or our
boyfriend or husband happy because we're
always trying to level level up either
be on the same level then we'll be even
higher and that's him earning our
relationships not like people are in my
ego I don't see it like that I see like
I don't I don't I I'm sorry if I don't
understand you properly but I don't say
this as Larry my ego whatsoever because
it's like I'm seriously okay it's like
because I believe that for men that's my
concept that's my belief I believe for
me like oh no we would like to bingo
bang that makes it happen so go be happy
she's like very selfless as well like
it's not something that's gonna be like
oh my God this is oh you are talking to
no sometimes like like you see a girl
like a beautiful girl walk and say oh my
God she's so beautiful it's like I think
sometimes it it's like uh we miss
empathy it's like you know when you go
like to nightclubs and like someone is
like doing bad like he's in a bad moment
I always see like something that I like
to say I always see like girls coming up
to that person say hey dude are you fine
yeah hey can I get you something or or
someone in the bathroom okay you know
and like you're seeing that environment
because people are like relax you know
and so when I say like oh go be happy
it's not that I'm trying to like make um
learning but it's like I believe like if
you're both like in the same page you're
like what do you like but you can like
do things together and keep it like easy
because I think like the world outside
is already so hard yeah it's like it's
already gonna try to beat you to beat
you so much if you cannot get home and
like be with a person they're like truly
like like understands you like have you
by your side you know it should be like
peaceful it's gonna be really hard you
know yeah I think you can be like more
like empathic like this you know so if
he if he was um banging other girls and
accidentally he maybe got one
impregnated
oh okay 2014 so almost 10 years okay
that solves that problem yeah STDs
um I mean everyone you know like most of
the guys I know that I've been you know
with a lot of girls like usually it's
like chlamydia like one to five times or
something I'm not like bragging about it
but like gone in a week with a pill not
that big of a deal I've done videos on
STDs one and two people get that yeah
yeah it's pretty common but like she
also gets like turned on like hearing
about me with girls and she wants to see
like what would the girl look like and
stuff like that
um I I think the way you've gone about
it I say more power to you know I think
there's a lot of men will be watching us
thinking this guy's a little please
really the honesty and coming to to
terms with like the rules and stuff like
that like I'm not getting emotionally
attached with these other girls yeah I'm
not taking it how do you stop that
though what if you just meet someone
that's incredible and you no but men can
easily detached yeah no but people think
that men don't have emotions you do what
if you just met someone you just thought
I just want to spend time with her more
and more we've had that we've had that
happen a couple times
there was an Argentinian girl that was
like she was like Argentinian polish in
Ukraine Ukrainian so like Eastern
European with the South American yeah
she was like great so you fell in love
with her no I didn't fall in love but
like
I was like seeing her a bunch and like
she got jealous of Liz because she liked
me a lot yeah the thing is usually they
get jealous of me not me getting jealous
I open my house it's like you're in the
car like yeah it's like no not because
of this because I believe like dude if
they are both cool so okay you're very
powerful you've clearly done a hell of a
lot of work in yourself
and then like she got there and I was
like okay like but she knows the end of
the day like like we have we have like a
very loving relationship and like all
the stuff that you'd expect like from a
partner we have all that and there's
like this other thing on the side but
it's not but it doesn't really detract
it's just like something it's a special
circumstance that's my job yeah I I am
so curious though what if she said a
personal trainer started to like him and
she did want to engage with him what is
it about the rules that would stop you
allowing her to be the guy it's just
like 100 off limits for my side but why
the sodas I get it as a bloke
I tell them why I don't want some guy
being my chick yeah I guess I think it's
double standards
yeah I'm wondering okay but even as
women like do you want to bang a bunch
of dudes no no
sometimes it's like I can say like oh
sometimes um like John arrives oh let's
you know let's have sex sometimes I'm
like so tired and it's like
um can you like you know so I I I'm fine
if I say like oh not tonight you know
because I know he's gonna be fine and
I'm not like you know cutting him like
so you know and it's not like something
that's like I feel I need so much
because I'm there's so many activities
that I want to do that's the truth
there's so many things that I want to do
that
so when he goes and bangs and like come
back happy it's like oh this is this is
done check so this is fine no no so I
can do my stuff so you have like this
thing together you know like we won't
help each other
like you know when they say activities
they say like stupid like painting
I love painting every guy wants to be
John right now why does he help you so
you help a lot yeah yeah
he is awesome he's like he's really help
you financially yes like I used to have
a job and it was like that thing
um they don't make much in Brazil
right I did a lot of my job seriously I
love my job but the problem is being
inside of my job and having to take care
of like the House John like the dogs it
was like just like too much for me why
because like I would do everything like
kind of and I hate that feeling because
it like really starts to like uh stress
me out so and then he was like dude you
can like do these little things here and
this because it provides you give back
yeah that way exactly like I understand
no yeah so it's like it's it's not hard
privilege yeah it's not it's not like a
hard thing you know babe we need that so
God forbid he lost his job he's gonna
have to get back to monogamy real
quickly
but it's like when I first met him to be
honest like today we have like oh Maids
we have people talk the dogs we have
everything but when I first met him and
you have everything that we can buy it
won't buy and you don't care about so
many uh expensive so for us it's easy
you know like we uh he makes uh some
amount that we don't even have time to
spend like let's say like that so it's
easy it's not like how but like when I
first met him like three years ago he
wasn't rich he didn't have like that
much money and he was like he did that
stuff like we always try to help and it
wasn't like unless you have to do this
you have to do no it was like uh I can
do this so you can do that I can do this
you can do that there was a point that
like his company was doing bad and I was
like in my job and I was just think dude
if it goes bad because like he likes
some stuff but I was just saying oh am I
able to take us with my wage for some
time and I was to say okay so I need to
work a little bit more here so I was
willing to do that because like I chose
for
it's it's like for his mind you know I
think his mind is really fascinating for
me but I found I found that the girls
that say like he has to he has to earn
my submission or he has to make him a
bunch of money they're just keeping
score yeah like relationships aren't
good if you're keeping score of what
he's doing for you and what you're doing
for him yeah
just bam
talk
it's on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible